[Music]
I'm vanilla the product manager at
Google and I'm Gila for I'm a developer
advocate for a Google Cloud and I'm also
a Java champion and I'd be curious to
know who's a Java developer in the
audience yeah awesome you're in the
right place today a quick housekeeping
note I know all of you are using the app
here for the conference so we have a
Dory for Question and Answer so feel
free to pour in your questions as the
talk goes on and we'll address them at
the end so let's get started so here's a
quick agenda for the talk so we're going
to give you a brief oh you of service at
Google cloud and then specifically get
into the what's new in Java and
serverless and after that provide a demo
we have an exciting demo over a broad
range of products and then conclude with
service beyond compute for certain
additional offerings beyond our compute
spectrum so to start off with what is
service in Google cloud so our
definition of service in Google cloud is
to build and run software without
provisioning managing or maintaining
physical or virtual machines completely
easing the pain of the users just give
us your code and we'll run it for you
furthermore to elaborate on that we
consider that to be an operating model
zero server management we considered to
be completely secure and pay for only
what you use in terms of a billing model
additionally we want a developer
experience and a programming model
focused around service based management
so you build your own micro services
that you deploy in the cloud we want it
to be event-driven so you submit a you
know flower you know image to a GCS
bucket and you trigger a cloud function
or any of them and submit a pub sub
message or any other activity that you
have to trigger sprinkles of compute of
cloud in the cloud
lastly we want to be open with zero
vendor lock-in and
these are the two paradigms around which
we define serverless an operating model
and a programming model and we have what
we call a full stack service offering in
Google Cloud spread across seven areas a
bunch of compute offerings but over a
broad other areas such as storage DevOps
data analytics messaging ml nai and
smart and chat pods a lot of these
technologies you know are decade-long of
Google engineering experience exposed to
you
for example bigquery is like a big
engine that we have worked on for
several years and we expose that as a
service offering for you in this talk
we're going to jump deeper into some of
the compute offerings especially and
also the Java offerings in this space so
to start off with you know we want to
talk about cloud functions which is in
compute a source based event-driven
functions a simple example would be like
you submit an image to Google Cloud
storage and you want some work done on
it so you can trigger a bunch of api's
to do that work
after cloud functions the next thing in
the spectrum we talk about is App Engine
App Engine is our you know decades-long
old service offering if you want to
build a simple web app you know in your
favorite programming language it's
stateless server less offerings we
consider App Engine is something for
that and then we have latest offering
which is cloud run which is service
containers for fully managed HTTP
request/response
which can be run on a fully managed
system within cold cloud as well as on
kubernetes engine so dig deeper into
cloud functions specifically as I
mentioned before we consider cloud
functions as our event driven service
compute platform what we vision is as
triggering sprinkles of compute of cloud
which basically then help you build your
applications of you know gluing together
code to run your various services for
example you have different cloud
services that could event invoke cloud
functions that invoke different api's
with the result of which is then
processed by these services as I said
upload an image to cloud storage do some
work using an ml API the result of which
could then be stored in Google Cloud
storage as well
it's a fully managed offering it scales
automatically and it's pay per use we
consider to be a streamlined development
model where you write your function and
deploy it with a single command and it
has integration for events with
different GCP products as well as HTTP
classic use cases for cloud functions
could be like web hooks you know you
have different clients that you know
invoke a web hook and then that could
start triggering HTTP function to
process some work you can invoke
different API through a cloud function
such as the ml API and so on and events
events are very imperative for example a
good use case for this could be is like
if you had bigquery and you had a lot of
audit logs that you want to track and
you went through logging activity such
as a stag driver which fires events you
could then use functions to process
those events and do some analytics on
that the next queues case will be
lightweight ETA for example like you
upload certain data to cloud storage and
then you can trigger a cloud function to
do some processing on that data and
install the analysis in a in a datastore
and lastly IOT and edge devices if you
have different edge devices deployed
across all our regions like if you're an
oil company or any other company you can
you know those events could be fired and
then into the cloud maybe through a
messaging system and then you invoke a
function to do some processing to store
the results so these broad range of use
cases can be accommodated under cloud
functions or function as a service as we
call it currently cloud functions is
often in these runtimes they're all GA
in the same runtimes we have you know
additional versions which are beta on
alpha and today we are really excited to
announce Java and cloud functions
thank you thank you the team's been
working really hard for it many of the
engineers are sitting right here
so you know like we have been really
excited to get this ready for you and to
go deep dive into cloud functions in
general as a product we would also
recommend you go attend the run cloud
functions everywhere talk it's for my
colleagues do it right sling it's a very
exciting talk and I highly recommend it
going on from crowd functions to App
Engine so as I mentioned before App
Engine is you know our ten-year old
service offering it was one of the
earliest service offerings if you want
to build your traditional web app on
your favorite language there's no J's
Python or Java you can use App Engine
along with frameworks such as X plus
flask and spring the product has various
advanced management features such as
application versioning traffic splitting
IP firewalls logging monitoring and so
on we've come here on times which are
all GA such as PHP go node.js further we
are really excited to have Java 11 on
App Engine as well as Ruby further not
moving down what I talked about the most
recent offering which is cloud run which
is service agility for country arised
apps we've talked about a lot in lex
recently and i want to elaborate a
little bit more about it what this
basically means is taking a container
from production to deployment in seconds
just give us a container in any language
or any library and with a single command
it gets immediately deployed Google
Cloud and you have a URL in seconds
further we consider this to be a
natively service offering what this
basically means is you don't as I
mentioned before you don't have to
manage any servers just focus on writing
your code it scales up very quickly it
scales down to zero and you pay exactly
for what you use the lifecycle of a
request and it's one experience where
you want to want it what this basically
means is you have a unified developer
experience on where you want to run your
application for example like if you want
fully managed deployment within Google
Cloud you could if you want to run it on
gke cloud run works on cloud run and gke
where you get additional control on your
cluster and if you don't want to run it
on google clara at all this
anti-technology is based on what is
called key native and you can run key
native on your on-prem systems on
kubernetes and run your containers there
by doing this we want to make sure that
you have the full spectrum of offerings
across the cloud and on-premise systems
and with zero when the lock-in so now
what's the Java story for server lists
so we're excited announced as I
mentioned Java 8 on Google cloud
functions furthermore we have Java 11 on
App Engine standard it's it's a great
offering and I highly recommend you to
try it and then we have Java on cloud
run where you can run your favorite
frameworks such as spring and so on on
our cloud realm offering given this we
now like to try a demo we have an
exciting demo vacuum and we'll take it
from there
could you switch to the demo please
thank you so taught functions App Engine
Quadron will demonstrate the three
products so here is the typical screen
from the cloud console and we have a
couple of functions which are already
deployed and so when you create a
function what happens so let's say hello
next what's new for you today Java the
offerors it's the fact that we now have
this line Java 8 alpha that you can see
here and it allows me to write my java
code here so I have a Java file here and
I also have a pond dot XML file because
when you do a source deployment of your
Java functions where you're using maven
to build your java code but you can also
do fat jar jar deployment as well so
here if you have already pre compiled on
your using for example
from bill tool such as Gradle you can do
that without needing maven but here when
you do source deployments we build
transparently for you in cloud build and
we're using maven for that so let's have
a look at what we can actually start
with the pom dot XML this maven build
file so notice that I'm specifying Java
eight for compilation purpose because
I'm using Java 8 and I added this
servlet dependency because we're using
the the servlet dependency here and
perhaps I can put it there it might be a
bit bigger and should be more readable
so this is a simple class and we have
our processing function which is cool
sorry which is called hello world it
takes a request parameter
httpservletrequest as well as
httpservletresponse then from the
response I'm getting the writer and I'm
gonna write on the output my little
hello world message
so I've already deployed it earlier and
I can easily test it from there haha
testing and then it's gonna call my
function and print hello world yes but
since it's it's about Java but it's not
just about joy in the sense that on the
Java ecosystem there are also
alternative languages so I wanted to
show you the fact that we can also run
with other Java frenzy languages so I
have another example I can show you that
for example in my visual studio code I'm
using groovy I'm the Apache groovy
co-founder so that's why I'm biased and
I like this language on the JVM so it's
pretty simple it's just a groovy script
with similarly to what we had with the
Java 8 we just have the process method
here no need for class or anything
surrounding this and same thing I'm
getting the writer and I'm writing on
the output and I just wanted to show you
as well so since we did the the
deployment earlier with the console the
web console you can also deploy it from
there
with g-cloud on the on the command line
with g-cloud functions deploy the name
of my function i specify that I want to
use the Java 8 runtime even if it's a
another language that's ok
HTTP trigger and the entry point that's
actually main that's the name of my
groovy script and process the name of
the method and I'm doing I'm doing a
deployment from source I'm saying
- - source dot I can also do that for
jar so if I have a fat jar already
precompiled I can also deploy it from
from there and then just to prove that
it works I can show you testing and it
should print all groovy world in a few
milliseconds yes hello guru Bo so we saw
HTTP functions but we also support
background functions such as new file
uploaded to cloud storage and you want
to be notified and have your functions
being invoked when this is when you
finally stored pub/sub when you receive
messages on a topic from pub/sub etc and
actually I didn't mention that as I was
using the default HTTP select box here
but you can also specify ok I want to
create a pubsub method and you can see
this is still note sorry and you have
some of the samples here too to help you
get get started and to illustrate those
background functions I would like to
highlight this demonstration here if you
go to the showcase on the exhibition
floor there's a cloud functions demo
which is running that's called a service
postcard and it's a little application
which allows you to select a picture for
example this one you can customize and
give a little message there yellow
attendees and it's going to process my
picture with all the runtimes that we
have so note Python go and Java and
notice that Java is pretty fast right
same as fastest it's actually the
fastest yes so I'm not going to say
anything I don't want to I mean if they
are non Java developers you know
the other runtimes are totally great but
my function was superfast in Java and it
was it was fasting too as well and then
so you can click on the view cut button
to see what the code looks like and
there's a little sharing button which
puts a message on Twitter and shares
this picture and I wanted to show you
the this architecture diagram so what do
we have that's an angular application
which is also using firebase from with a
an ajax call it's going to call a first
java function this HTTP function here we
pass the name of the the file the
picture the the picture file name and as
well as the message this function is
going to post a little request on pepsin
on a particular topic and then this
message because those four functions
here in go python node and java are
going to be woken up because there's new
message coming up on a topic so those
functions here are pub sub functions
triggered fraction functions then those
functions will process the picture you
know add the the frame type the message
etc and once they are done they are
going to save the resulting picture in
cloud storage since we start something
on cloud storage there's going to be
another a synchronous event notifying
another Java function which will
retrieve all the pictures and update
some metadata in my cloud fire store
database and also because I'm using
firebase on the front end I'm able to
update the front-end as soon as I gather
all the URLs of the pictures that have
been processed so what I'd like to show
you is one of the Java functions the one
doing the image processing which is a
pub sub function and the one doing the
cloud storage even handling so let's
have a look at the code here
so this is my Image Processor I'm gonna
hide that to have a bit more space so
this function is going to receive a
pub/sub message so that's my process
method the pub/sub message actually
under the hood we're using the ji-sun
library which does marshaling and
marshaling of json to and from java
objects and if you go at the very bottom
actually there's my pub sub class here
that's and marshalled and this i'm
interested in the data field because
this data field contains my image
request payload with the file name
message etc so I'm recently receiving
that's right I also have access to it's
an optional parameter there's a context
if I need some additional data but the
event ID timestamp even type resources
etc I'm not using it in the function
that I will need to to show this this
context class then I'm just dickering
the the data from the pub sub message
and there I'm using JSON directly
because I know that what's in the
payload of the purpose of message is
actually some JSON content so I want to
get an instance of my image request
which contains the the file name etc I'm
doing a bit of cloud storage handling
because I want to retrieve or is it yeah
image download to I want to retrieve the
image from cloud storage that's where I
store all my pictures and then there's a
long part of the code you know how to
look at it too closely where I'm
actually using Java 2d to do the image
generation and when I go towards the end
once I've drawn my picture I'm going to
write that and store that again in
another bucket in cloud storage so
that's what I'm doing there actually ok
so this new processed image is in cloud
straight so it's going to invoke as
components Li another function which I
call the watch
dog which is going to update firestore
with this new information so similarly I
have a GCS even that's actually myself
who created and defined this class at
the bottom I just used the bucket and
the name feels but there are other
additional attributes but I'm just
interested in those two so I just create
a simple class with those two fields and
then here I'm going to use firestore to
specify how I'm doing some reg X stuff
to retrieve the the name of the runtime
and things like that and once I have
that made a data I'm going to put the
information in firestore I've got my
document reference and then I'm gonna
here set the data in fire store and then
that's what is going later on to update
the UI here with so if I do another
little tests with some random message
that's once the data is stored in the
fire store it's a very ating the
pictures down below so that's about it
for functions in Java HTTP functions
background functions with cloud storage
and pops up all right so let's now have
a look at App Engine so I have a
prepared another little demo where you
upload a picture and it's going to be
well it's someone somehow artistic in a
way so I'm redrawing the picture with
some squares circles and letters so here
I'm gonna take a picture that I have
locally here so I'm going to take a
picture of one of our colleagues Roberto
who was one of the one of the architects
behind Java EE and also one of the key
engineers working on App Engine Java so
it's a bit unfortunate that he's not
there with us anymore because he passed
away recently but I wanted to show that
we we had him in our thoughts
and I'm going to use as the for the
letters I'm gonna use his first name I'm
submitting that and it's gonna draw so
I'm uploading the picture and then it
takes a second or two to draw the
picture and here is an artistic vision
of this original picture so I'd like to
show you how I implemented that with App
Engine Java 11 so I'm gonna switch to
here so what do you see here for first
thing I'd like to highlight is that
you're not limited to servlet based web
frameworks you can use any web framework
that you want to create your App Engine
applications on the java 11 runtime so
that's why I decided to use micro node
it's a super fast with super slow
startup frameworks which is pretty
pretty straightforward and pretty easy
to use so I have a controller here for
which I actually inject my solve this
class that's going to do the image
manipulation I have so here I'm serving
the static assets with the the form and
here mostly more more interestingly
that's the URL when the the the form
that you saw earlier is going to post
the picture and the message and the
letters that have chosen to this process
endpoint through a multi platform and
either I'm going to return okay if
everything goes fine or the server error
and here this is the part where I'm
actually calling my service artist
service which is here and so it's a
singleton service that I injected
earlier and then I'm doing again some
Java 2d you're going to think I'm a fan
of Java 2d too so I get the the bytes of
the picture I'm going to return the the
bytes of the process the image and then
well some Java 2d stuff Java 2d 2d and
then I'm outputting I'm putting the
bytes
back and that's what these service
returns so that's basically how it was
implemented but let me have a look at
the optional file so I mentioned that we
don't have to use solid based frameworks
here I'm using actually just a fat job
that I compiled here so I'm using Gradle
for the build but it's irrelevant here I
created a fat jar of my application I
can deploy and notice that I I'm sorry
that I actually have full control of the
entry point meaning that I can you know
pass things like garbage collection
parameters I can pass any kind of
parameter to customize the way I'm gonna
launch and invoke the the Java the Java
come in so far jars not limited to
sublight based payloads workloads
and a full control on how the Java
command is invoked so really no limits
anymore thanks to this new Java 11
runtime and my last demo that's this one
so this time I decided to use cloud run
so it's a little Sudoku puzzle generator
so you can generate as many puzzles as
you want so it's I'm using the Google
cloud hexagons the logos I can define
different levels I want a hard puzzle I
want an easy puzzle etc and the thing is
I had a there was a tool that I was
interested in using called qqing that's
the name of the project which is a
pseudo code generator and solver but
it's a binary application so I don't
necessarily have I wanted somehow to be
able to use that binary C C++
application within the context of my
java application first thing second
thing I wanted to experiment with new
features of Java the java language for
example java 12 as added
new experimental feature actually which
is the the new switch expression which
are more streamlined compared to the old
switch case so let me show you what I
did
so just because I can I thought that I
could use yet another framework and I'm
using I should start from the bottom
there here so there's lots of red in
Visual Studio code that's because I'm
using the new Java syntax constructs
that are not supported yet in Visual
Studio code so that's why there's lots
of red underline so here I'm using the
rat-pack framework which is also very
lightweight framework not based on
solids and which is using the neti
library so I define my server I say I'm
listening on port 8080 I'm serving some
static content for example for the
pictures of the eggs Agins
and then I've got two two routes so I
have one for displaying the pictures the
exec owns and the other one which is the
one which generates the pseudo coos and
I'm passing a path parameter which is
the the level here and what I wanted to
do is to be able to use this Javits will
have experimental switch expression
notation so notice that it's a little
bit different compared to the old switch
case statement so you can specify
different values like easy and cool on
the same line and you're using an arrow
instead of the comment and you don't
have to use the break so for that I
really need it to use Java twelve of
course
I could have used an if-else statement
but you know just because I can I did it
so I have this switch statement and I
also wanted to show here that I'm using
the process builder to invoke my pseudo
code generator so that's what i'm using
i'm i'm doing here i'm starting the
process and i'm going to retrieve the
output of this c c++ program and let me
show you what my build and my docker
container look like so as you can see in
my belt I'm using Gradle for the for the
build
as you can see I specified that I won't
use the Java 12 syntax level but when
I'm compiling my color I'm also using
this special Java compiler flag enable
preview which enables this new
experimental syntax what else that's
about it here I'm also using the the
shadow plug-in which is doing a which
creates fat jars when you use Gradle for
the bill and the docker file let's have
a look at the locker for dr. Fry so it's
a naughty stage docker
bill I actually have the first step
which is about building my application
and invoking the shadow jar coming to
create my fat jar so this is this part
building my app but then here's the
image I'm gonna use and that I'm gonna
push on cloud run so I need it oops
sorry
I needed my little binary file here for
generating the pseudo cooze and I'm
retrieving from the first stage of my
build I'm returning the the fat jar and
then what else I'm exposing port 8080
and then I can specify the entry point
as well and specify ok I'm launching a
jar and I'm enabling this preview
feature that should be available when
I'm running my code and then so if you
look at the very bottom you can see how
I built with docker and then docker run
so I can run that locally without a
problem and then I must have somewhere
doctor push command well somewhere in my
history it's too far so I can very
easily again push my own whichever
version of Java that I want to use in my
application
here I'm using Java 12 and yeah and I
can use of course anything that can be
put in the docker container basically I
can put that there and then I have my
service running here my pseudo code
generators service running in the in the
cloud run
console yes that's about it for the
demos yeah thank you for the exciting
demo um so as you also we saw our Java
offerings across trial functions App
Engine and cloud run with the live demo
just super exciting demo thank you very
much thank you thank you so switching
back to the slides
as we move on with our talk we're gonna
talk about service beyond compute and
specifically the thing that we want to
talk about here was you know server
computers not just a vacuum
you know you need ancillary products to
work with service offerings to build an
end-to-end service for example let's say
you want to run a cloud function but you
want to run it on a schedule like every
Friday morning or so on to do some work
or you want to queue a bunch of tasks or
a bunch of functions to be executed at a
later point in time
a month later a week later or so on all
you want sort of retry semantics then
you need some kind of cue to cue those
works to various micro services or
further if you want to store your end
results in a datastore you need a data
store where you can store the result for
place your ml work being processed from
a cloud function so given that I'm going
to talk to you about two specific
products that could help in building
these end-to-end applications the first
is cloud tasks cloud task is a
point-to-point queuing system for
asynchronous tasks across microservices
it's a queueing product for reliable
tasks offloading it's a fully managed
service if you have any long-running
async work such as you have like a job
that needs to be run to process an image
and the end result of the processing
needs to be stored somewhere you can
queue it up in this particular product
it has really good rate limits and retry
controls in in queueing systems it's
very important if if you have a workflow
of systems that you set a limit to the
weakest link in the chain Cloud toss
really gives the end users a control to
set these rate limits and retry
semantics so based on the guarantee
needs of your system you can tweak it
accordingly
further applause for flexible routing
with HTTP art so you can hit your
endpoints and services securely within
Google Cloud as well as your on-prem
systems to to know more about route to
us and it's you know retry semantics it
rates its rate limits dynamic scheduling
and other features we have a dedicated
session for this called cloud toss
point-to-point asynchronous tasks across
Microsoft System are oh you know we
really appreciate it if you can come
there and you know it's an exciting
product and the team's work really hard
for it moving on you know as you're
building the systems we always need like
a cron system for example if you're
scheduling functions every Friday you
need something that you can set your
schedules on and at Google Cloud we have
protocol cloud scheduler it's what we
call the cron for the cloud it's a
reliable enterprise-grade con scheduler
that can reach different endpoints such
as HTTP pubs and App Engine targets it's
fully managed and pay for what you use
it supports the popular unix cron syntax
and as a delightful UI experience so you
can create your schedules from the UI as
well as you know the CLI furthermore you
have a really good monitoring dashboard
so you can track the status of your jobs
to the UI and also take corrective
action wherever necessary this this is
something that is very common we have
seen a lot of customers use you know
cloud functions coupled with cloud
scheduler on a recurring schedule they
really like the UNIX grant syntax so and
so you know we highly recommend you know
you're trying this product out as well
additionally it offers security so you
can hit these different endpoints with
security and authentication both within
your Google cloud as well as your
on-prem systems two more to know more
about cloud scheduler you know like we
have a session service and real world
the customer stories from small cities
to retail analytics it's by Bret McGowen
one of our developer advocates and we
have a 15 minute dedicated session from
one of our customers who's using the
product so
we highly recommend that you attend this
session as well so that's pretty much
the summary of our talk and in terms of
next steps we highly encourage you to
try our java offerings on google cloud
you know we also recommend you to sign
up for the cloud functions on Java 8
here's a QR code you know if you have
any questions feel free to reach out to
us anytime
both our contacts are here and we have
another Java talk by one of our
developer kids race sang we talked about
a lot of service offerings here for Java
but even if you want to run Java
applications on kubernetes and do a deep
dive on that he has a really good
session on that and you know it's really
exciting as well to summarize we've
spoken to you about various Java
offerings across cloud functions app
engine as well as cloud run and you know
these are really interesting products
and giving you the option to pick and
choose what you want based on your needs
is something that we wanted to do and
we've demoed that as well with Guillaume
here so yeah at this point we're thank
you very much for in the talk
[Applause]
[Music]